the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video in this video
i want to have another look at george rr
martin's original ending for a song of
ice and fire now this is something i
have made videos about before i like
looking at this at least once every six
months i've always been fascinated by
this outline because it shows us what
george rr martin originally had in mind
for his a song of ice and fire saga now
for those of you that don't know george
wrote this outline back in 1993 long
before he would ever release his first
book a game of thrones looking at this
you can see a lot of his early ideas
never made it into the books however
some of them did as you all know every
one of his fans are eagerly awaiting for
his ending of a song of ice and fire
although he has gone in a very different
direction than his original outline i
think it's still fun to see where things
could have gone if he followed this in
the future the outline gives us a
glimpse of how he initially saw his saga
ending i want to look at this again
because i know some of you haven't heard
me discuss this before
some of you likely haven't seen this at
all most of you were not watching my
videos back then and as far as i know i
haven't made one about it since game of
thrones ended so let's see how much of
this stayed the same you never know
maybe some of it will still show up in
the novels one way or another now let's
have a look at the first page it says
dear ralph here are the first 13
chapters of the high fantasy novel i
promised you which i'm calling a game of
thrones when completed this will be the
first volume and what i see as an epic
trilogy with the overall title a song of
ice and fire as you can see the names
have stayed the same the only thing that
is different here are the amount of
books he won't write at first he thought
there would only be three but now we
know there will be at least seven as of
right now he also says as you know i
don't outline my novels i find that if i
know exactly where a book is going i
lose all interest in writing it i do
however have some strong notions as to
the overall structure of the story i'm
telling and the eventual fate of many of
the main characters and the drama now
this might actually explain why he
hasn't released the wins of winner maybe
he really has lost all interest in
writing it because he knows where it
will end anyways he says roughly
speaking there are three major conflicts
set in motion and the chapters enclosed
these will form the major plot threads
of the trilogy intertwining each other
in what should be a complex but exciting
narrative tapestry each of the conflicts
presents a major threat to the peace of
my imaginary realm the seven kingdoms
and to the lives of my main characters
this sounds exactly like a song of ice
and fire the first threat grows from the
animosity between the great houses of
lannister and stark as it plays out in a
cycle of plot counter plot ambition
murder and revenge with the iron throne
of the seven kingdoms as the ultimate
prize this will form the backbone of the
first volume of the trilogy at game of
thrones okay i believe this is what
happened the novel a game of thrones
that we all know and love did not
deviate that much from his original
outline while the lion of lannister and
the direwolf of stark snarl and scrap
however a second and greater threat
takes shape across the narrow sea where
the dothraki horse lords mask their
barbarian hordes for a great invasion of
the seven kingdoms led by the fierce and
beautiful daenerys stormborn the last of
the targaryen dragonlords the dothraki
invasion will be the central story of my
second volume a dance with dragons this
sounds right as well although it did not
happen in the second book we would not
get a dance with dragons until his fifth
book the greatest danger of all however
is from the north from the icy waste
beyond the wall where have forgotten
demons at a legend the inhuman others
race called legions of the undead and
the never born and prepare to ride down
on the winds of winter to extinguish
everything that we would call life the
only thing that stands between the seven
kingdoms and an endless knight is the
wall and a handful of men in black
called the night's watch their story
will be at the heart of my third volume
the winds of winter the final battle
will also draw together characters and
threads left from the first two books
and resolve all in one massive climax
alright so as you can see the backbone
of his overall story is not that much
different from his original outline the
main thing that is different are the
amount of books he wrote if we only saw
this we would all most likely think he
hasn't changed anything at all it's
really interesting to see that he knew
what most of the major threads would be
before he even finished writing a game
of thrones in fact he had only wrote 13
chapters when he made the outline so he
was barely underway when he had all of
these different amazing ideas in mind i
find that fascinating although i guess
that's what separates a good writer from
a great writer now let me show you what
else he said the 13 chapters on hand
should give you a notion as to my
narrative strategy all three books will
feature a complex mosaic of intercutting
points of view among various of my large
and diverse cast of characters the cast
will not always remain the same old
characters will die and new ones will be
introduced some of the fatalities will
include sympathetic viewpoint characters
i want the reader to feel that no one is
ever completely safe not even the
characters who seem to be the heroes
we're all looking at you house stark the
suspense always ratchets up a notch when
you know that any character can die in
any moment now this is something george
r martin is amazing at unfortunately
it's something game of thrones lost in
its later seasons alright now let me
show you what he said on the second page
this is where things get really
interesting because although his overall
story structure has remained the same so
far here you will see how different some
of his finer details were some of our
favorite characters were heading in
drastically different directions in the
original outline he goes on to say five
central characters will make it through
all three volumes however growing from
children to adults and changing the
world and themselves in the process in a
sense my trilogy is almost a
generational saga telling the life
stories of these five characters three
men and two women the five key
characters are tyrion lannister daenerys
targaryen
and three of the children of winterfell
arya bran and the bastard jon snow all
of them are introduced at some length in
the chapters you have on hand now this
is very interesting because i do wonder
if all of these characters will survive
a song of ice and fire as you all know
all of these characters did survive game
of thrones except for daenerys targaryen
as i read some more of the outline you
will see george had some other ideas in
mind for our mother of dragons maybe he
will also change some things that will
happen in her end he says this is going
to be quite an epic epic in its scale
epic in its action and epic in its
length i see all three volumes as big
books running about 700 to 800
manuscript pages so things are just
barely getting underway in the 13
chapters i've sent you well he was right
about that these would be very big books
he went from writing only three to now
needing at least seven to finish his
story i have quite a clear notion of how
the story is going to unfold in the
first volume of game of thrones things
will get a lot worse for the starks
before they get better i'm afraid lord
eddard stark and his wife catelyn are
both doomed and will die at the hands of
their enemies ned will discover what
happened to his friend john aaron but
before he can act on that knowledge king
robber will have an unfortunate accident
and a throne will go to his solemn and
brutal son joffrey who is still a minor
joffrey will not be sympathetic and ned
will be accused of treason but before he
is taken he will help his wife and
daughter arya escape back to winterfell
once again almost all of this happened
except for ned helping his wife and
daughter escape back to winterfell
everything else right here is on the
money each of the contending families
will learn it has a member of dubious
loyalty in its midst sansa stark wed to
joffrey baratheon will bear him a son
the heir to the throne and when the
crunch comes she will choose her husband
and child over her parents and siblings
a choice she will later bitterly rue
tyrion lannister meanwhile will befriend
both sansa and her sister arya while
growing more and more disenchanted with
his own family now this is where things
went in a very different direction
as we all know sansa and joffrey did not
get married nor did they have a son it
also says young bran will come out of
his coma after a strange prophetic dream
only to discover that he will never walk
again he will look the magic at first in
the hope of restoring his legs but later
for its own sake when his father eddard
stark is executed bran will see the
shape of doom descending on all of them
but nothing he can say will stop his
brother robb from calling the banners in
rebellion all of the north will be
inflamed by war robb will win several
splendid victories and maim joffrey
baratheon on the battlefield but in the
end he will not be able to stand against
jaime and tyrion lannister and their
allies robb stark will die in battle and
tyrion lannister will besiege and burn
winterfell what it says here about bran
stark is accurate all of this did happen
however what it says about rob and
tyrion is very different than what we
got unfortunately rob did not hurt
joffrey on the battlefield nor is that
where rob died now although i did not
want rob to die i am glad it was at the
red wedding because i think that made
for a much better scene and as we all
know lorterian did not burn down
winterfell that was ramsay let's see
what it says about jon
it says jon snow the bastard will remain
in the far north he will mature into a
ranger of great daring and ultimately
will succeed his uncle as the commander
of the night's watch when winterfell
burns catelyn stark will be forced to
flee the north with her son brian and
her daughter arya wounded by lannister
riders they will seek refuge at the wall
but the men of the night's watch give up
their families when they take the black
and john and benjen will not be able to
help it will lead to a better
estrangement between jon and bran arya
will be more forgiving until she
realizes that she has fallen in love
with jon who is not only her
half-brother but a man of the night's
watch sworn to celibacy their passion
will continue to torment jon and arya
throughout the trilogy until the secret
of jon's parentage is finally revealed
in the last book now this is insane i am
so glad george did not have arya and jon
start a romantic relationship with one
another this may also help explain why
they do have so much love for each other
he most likely was setting this up in
the first book before he ultimately
decided to go in another direction
that's why we see john and arya thinking
about each other so much we can also see
that catelyn's original story was very
different we never saw her at castle
black there are some fans who think she
will show up at castle black as lady
stoneheart right around when jon is
resurrected that would be very
interesting if so especially considering
how much she already hated jon before
she died now that she's this angry
hellbent lady stoneheart who knows how
she would react if she saw him now
alright now let's have a look at the
last page of the outline it says
abandoned by the night's watch catelyn
and her children will find their only
hope of safety lies even further north
beyond the wall where they fall into the
hands of mance raider the king be on the
wall and get a dreadful glimpse of the
inhuman others as they attack the
wildling encampment bran's magic arya
sword needle and the savagery of their
direwolves will help them survive but
their mother catelyn will die at the
hands of the others it's hard for me to
even imagine this if arya would have
been with brain the whole time and not
jojo namira would he have ever met the
three-eyed raven it says bran has magic
but it never does say how he acquired it
i'm also glad catelyn was at the red
wedding instead of dying out beyond the
wall as interesting as that may have
been i still think the red wedding is a
much better idea it was easily one of
the single greatest moments in all of a
song of ice and fire over across the
narrow sea daenerys will discover that
her new husband the dothraki called
drogo has little interest in invading
the seven kingdoms much to her brother's
frustration when viserys presses his
claim past a point of attack or wisdom
call drogo will finally grow annoyed and
kill him out of hand eliminating the
targaryen pretender and leaving daenerys
as the last of her line daenerys will
bide her time but she will not forget
when the moment is right she will kill
her husband to avenge her brother and
then flee with a trusted friend into the
wilderness beyond vast threat there
hunted by dothraki blood riders she
stumbles on the dragon eggs and she will
eventually bend them to her will then
she begins to plan for her invasion of
the seven kingdoms there are some slight
differences here daenerys obviously did
not kill drogo to avenge her brother
she also did not find the dragon eggs on
her own although i actually like that
better one of the knocks against her is
that she was given everything i think it
would have made things even more magical
if she would have found them on her own
as if something was leading her there
and lastly it says lord tyrion lannister
will continue to travel to plot and to
play the game of thrones finally
removing his nephew joffrey in disgust
at the boy king's brutality jaime
lannister will follow joffrey on the
throne of the seven kingdoms by the
simple expedient of killing everyone
ahead of him in the line of succession
and blaming his brother tyrion for the
murders after he's exiled tyrion
lannister will change sides making
common cause with the surviving starks
to bring his brother down and falling
helplessly in love with arya stark while
he's at it his passion is alas
unreciprocated but no less intense for
that and it will lead to a deadly
rivalry between tyrion and jon snow holy
smokes this is obviously extremely
different than what is in the song of
ice and fire novels here it does sound
like tyrion kills joffrey well it
actually only says he removed him it
doesn't necessarily say he murdered him
although that would make it better if
you ask me i am happy jaime and tyrion
were not fighting each other like they
were here i actually like their
relationship the way it is now or at
least the way it was before jaime
revealed what really happened with
tyrion's former wife one other thing
that i do not like about this is the
whole arya john and tyrion relationship
i don't know what the hell george was
thinking here but i don't like it
regardless of that i am still fascinated
with this original outline i love seeing
all these different ideas because it
does give us some insight into what
george rr martin saw for the characters
although some of it never did happen now
i'm sure some of you will hate the idea
that i made this video because of how
irrelevant most of this is however i do
hope some of you find this to be as
interesting as i do it's like stepping
into an alternate a song of ice and fire
universe you could almost consider it
the very first fanfiction only it was
written by the man himself now since
almost all of the major threads and
themes stayed the same i do wonder what
that means for daenerys it's obvious
george rr martin already had most of
this story well thought out in his head
considering daenerys is a main character
i wonder if she will still meet the same
fate he initially had in mind for her we
can see a lot of the smaller details are
different but that doesn't mean their
final scenes will be he originally
wanted her to live but maybe he no
longer feels the same way one day i hope
we find out leave me some of your
thoughts on this down below i'm always
interested in seeing what all of you
have to say as always i want to thank
you for watching my video i hope
everyone has a great day bye
[Music]
foreign